out of all the headlines to come out of
the events of this past weekend this is
surely my favorite from the independent
it reads right wing blogger launches
gofundme for aoc's puerto rico
grandmother
in latest personal attack actually let
me correct myself that's not my favorite
headline of the weekend
it's my favorite headline possibly of
all time and i feel that way even though
it misgenders me as a blogger which i'm
not
by the way not anymore um now now those
who missed the show on friday and uh
and made the good and healthy decision
to avoid the internet over the weekend
are no doubt extremely confused right
now so let me back up
and explain this story from the
beginning and then i'll talk about the
lessons that we can learn
now that the saga has reached its
dramatic conclusion so it began
last week when congresswoman alexandra
casa cortez tweeted out photographs of
her grandmother's dilapidated
home in puerto rico well it was
allegedly her grandmother's dilapidated
home in puerto rico
she explained that her dear abuela has
been living in this squalor with a
collapsing ceiling and buckets all over
the floor
to catch the rainwater ever since
hurricane maria a few years ago
she explained that of course it's
trump's fault that nobody has bothered
to fix abuela's ceiling in the past four
years
now i responded to her tweet reminding
her that she's a wealthy and famous
politician and that maybe she should
take care of her own family members
using the funds that she has personally
available
to her as a wealthy and famous
politician
she responded to me she clapped back as
the
left-wing blogs put it saying that she's
worried about not just her grandmother
but the systemic injustices in puerto
rico
and society in general and she can
accuse me of being unconcerned indeed
totally fine
with systemic injustices myself
she did not however promise that she
would personally pay to fix
her grandmother's ceiling that was a
noticeable omission
in her response so a day later i
launched a gofundme campaign
to repair and save abuela's home
if aoc is not going to help her family
members and is going to wait around for
the government to fix the problem then i
felt it had fallen to me
to do what aoc would not or could not do
i'm not judging her though i just want
to be clear she did just buy a new tesla
and those monthly payments could be
pretty steep
she also has two apartments and she's
making payments on those so she's got
money tied up and all that
and uh so you know i should probably
explain that to abuela and said listen
granny i'm sorry i got the two
apartments i got the tesla
you know you've got buckets right for
the rain water you'll be fine just make
sure you just
change those things out every couple
days now right after starting the
campaign i of course reached out to aoc
personally both on twitter and through
email
to try and coordinate with her to make
sure that the funds made it to her
abuela
she didn't respond to my messages indeed
she never publicly or privately
acknowledged the fundraiser at all least
of all did she thank me for it
i can't say i was surprised by that but
i also can't say that my feelings
weren't hurt
i'm a very sensitive and emotional guy
as you know
and uh that cut me pretty deep and yet
the fundraiser marched on
i wasn't doing this for personal
accolades
i was only partially doing it for
personal accolades mainly it was about
saving abuela's home and we made
stunning progress in that regard in the
space of just a few hours
many prominent people in right-wing
media including all of the hosts here at
the daily wire
as well as stephen crowder and dave
rubin and others all join the effort and
then in this space of 10 hours
get this we raised 100
000 in 10 hours
now think about that 100 grand in 10
hours
aoc couldn't apparently raise any money
for her abuela
in four years we raised a hundred
thousand dollars
in an afternoon on a friday
it was inspiring it was tremendous
we were arguably the most successful
charity troll campaign of all time it
also might have been the only charity
troll campaign of all time
but then things took a turn around 10
o'clock on friday night
um i just got back from dinner with my
wife
and i went to check the gofundme page
only to find that the donations had been
turned off
now it said on the page and this is what
confused me
it said that donations had been paused
quote by the organizer
but i thought i was the organizer and i
didn't pause them so that seemed sort of
strange
then a short time later i received this
email from the gofundme trust and safety
team this is what i read
this is what it said i'll read it to you
it said and
pay close attention to the language they
use here
dear matt we are in touch with the
beneficiary's
family and they have made clear that
they will not be accepting the funds
raised
when a beneficiary doesn't want to
accept the funds that have been raised
on their behalf
it is standard practice to turn off
donations then refund all donors we
recommend posting an update
on the fundraiser to let your donors
know that they will be fully refunded
within the next couple days
they'll also receive an automatic
message from gofundme informing them
of their refund they will get 100 of
their donation back three to seven
business days after the refunds are
issued
please let us know if you have any
questions and they did issue the refunds
i
i put 499 dollars into the campaign to
kick things off
which happens to be the um the monthly
lease payment for tesla
you know we just chose that amount
randomly and
i got the the refund yesterday i didn't
want it
i'm sorry abuela i tried as far as
questions i do have some
did abuela herself turn down the money
it says the beneficiary's family turned
it down but
we weren't raising money for her family
they have quite enough it would seem
like the tesla the two apartments you
know we were raising money for her
since when can the family the family of
a beneficiary
shut down a fundraising campaign and
more importantly why did they shut it
down
aoc showed us pictures of her abuela's
home
nearly falling apart by the looks of it
she was living in a crumbling shack and
had been living like that for years
we raised enough money to not only fix
her house but change her life and we did
that in 10 hours
imagine if we if it had gone on for
another two or three days
but we could have raised we could have
raised a million dollars
easily we could have and that could have
gone to
abuela and then they and then and and
they could have fixed up her home made
it perfect
and then they could have taken the rest
of the money if they wanted to because
it'd be their money
and they could have given it to a
charity in puerto rico to help other
people
they could we could have fixed up the
entire neighborhood
with that money and it was turned down
this is real money okay the money was
not a joke it's really there
the fact that someone in abuela's family
turned down the money
seems to indicate one of two things
either aoc would rather let her own
loved ones suffer
than accept help from conservatives and
not just her loved ones again
but the the whole community
the whole community could have benefited
from this
or and this is the other really
scandalous possibility
and i don't know if this is true or not
the other possibility is that she misled
the public
about abuela's living conditions were
those pictures
actually current photos of abuela's home
was it all a ruse
i don't know i mean she does seem to
have a history of
kind of exaggerating um her own personal
trauma and perhaps
that of those close to her i don't know
maybe we'll never know but either way
whatever the explanation whatever
motivated the whale's family to shut
down the fundraiser while not saying a
word about it publicly
the truth is unflattering to aoc to say
the least
we certainly exposed something through
this effort we could only speculate as
to what exactly that is
and honestly i am tired of aoc and
people like her
constantly using emotional blackmail and
supposed
personal trauma to score political
points in silence opposition
we called her on it this time in a big
way and i can guarantee you
she regrets ever bringing abuela into
the conversation if that's all we
achieved in the end
then i'd say it was more than worth it
but we achieved more than that
we proved another important point
tragedy and misfortune are often
exploited in order to push for
government action
and we're made to believe that the only
you know that only the government
can address these sorts of problems
but we addressed the problem and could
have solved it
in just one day through private action
and i i have to keep stressing i cannot
stress enough
a hundred thousand dollars in 10 hours
we could have gone to a million
easily and how far could that money have
gone
not just for abuela but for the whole
community
if they had chosen to share it
um there's a lesson here for those who
are willing to learn it
finally most of all we proved
that i am one of the world's leading
philanthropists i'm like bill gates
except without the sex parties or the
100 billion dollars so i guess i'm not
like
bill gates at all come to think of it
but i will now be throwing my hat into
the ring for a nobel peace prize i'm not
sure if that's how it works exactly but
i would like to announce that
i'll accept the award if it's offered to
me and i think we can all agree that i'm
deserving especially because
the award means absolutely nothing these
days anyway so you might as well give it
to a guy who trolled a politician by
raising a hundred thousand dollars for a
grandmother
why not now some people i know
uh are are may not be satisfied and
there are still questions about what we
did here
and why we did it there are some even on
the right
who object there were some on the right
who were offended by all of this
and let me know it and there are some
people still questioning
you know was it all just a big troll was
it a stunt
was it charitable was it proving a point
was it trying to solve a problem
was it a sincere attempt to raise money
for a cause
was it mean was it nice was it petty was
it generous
was it hilarious the answer in short
is yes well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt wall show if you did go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content